here's the five stages every new
entrepreneur goes through when they're
trying to pick their next business the
first thing they do is they get
uninformed optimism they get really
excited because they don't know what
they're actually about to do as they
learn more they realize that actually
this isn't all perfect it's all sunshine
and rainbows they transition to step two
informed pessimism they now see all the
stuff that's wrong with it step three is
they continue down that path until they
get to the very bottom which is the
valley of Despair they can see only the
bad stuff and at this point this is
where most people jump from that
opportunity back to uninformed optimism
to a new thing that they think is going
to be amazing and around and around they
go step four if you push through the
valley of Despair it becomes informed
optimism you understand both the upsides
and the downsides of the opportunity but
you know how to control for the downside
so that you get the upside and then
finally that takes you to step five
which is achievement of the goal people
go through these five stages but they
never get to four and five because they
continue to repeat and so if you're
going through hard times right now you
have to think to yourself am I just in
the valley of Despair and I need to push
through or am I just looking for another
out to start and ride this ride again